[موسيقى]
اول شيء لازم نعرف معلومه كل الشركات
التقنيه في الايام الماضيه قامت بفصل عدد
كبير موظفين فيسبوك طلب صرت اكثر من 11000
موظف شركات كثيره مشت في قرار فصل موظفين
عندهم وهذا ترى شيء مو جديد على شركات
التقنيه او الشركات بشكل عام لان كل
الشركات التقنيه خلال السنوات الماضيه نمت
نموم مضطره جدا كبير وللمعلوميه قرار فصل
الموظفين ترى اللي اعتذر عنه الرئيس
السابق لانه طلع في تغريده يتكلم قال انا
اتحمل جزء من مسؤوليه فصل الموظفين نحن
نظفنا اعداد كبيره جدا الموظفين في تويتر
رؤى انه ممكن يحققون ارباح معينه في ذلك
ابو عدد موظفين فالشغل
شخصين وهذا ساهم بشكل جديد جدا كبير في
زياده اعداد الموظفين بشكل جدا كبير
وتقليل كفاءه همم العمل في داخل شركه
[موسيقى]
النجا تويتر من القنوات المتسرعات قد ياخذ
خط يتبوا مكان جدا كويس في منصات التواصل
اجتماعيه كل منصات التواصل الاجتماعيه
خلال سنوات الماضيه نمت نمو جدا عالي
انستقرام انما نمو عالي جدا فيسبوك لما
نمو عالي جدا تيك توك طلع بعد تويتر لكن
تويتر اعداد المستخدمين في كانت بسيطه جدا
لذلك القرارات هذه والتسريعات هذه في فرصه
جدا كبيره وذه لتويتر انه ينمو ويصل الى
اعداد كبيره المستخدمين وياخذ مكان اخر لو
في حاله سمح الله صارت تعطل في خدمه
انتهاء خدمه معينه لم نشاط التواصل
اجتماعيه ترى ليست مستمره في منصات تواصل
اجتماعيه انتهت في منصات تواصل اجتماعيه
توقفت كانت في شبكات اجتماعيه موجوده
وانتهت حاليا هي ما هي موجوده في حياتنا
كانت موجوده 2000/ 2010
فلذلك تويتر اذا واصل النمو بشكل كويس
وغير من طريقه عمله وعنده فرصه جدا ذهبيه
ان يقدم خدمات كثيره ومستخدمين وينمو نمو
جدا كبير